[Music]
tim
hmm have you ever heard of thailand's
defamation laws
and how crazy they can be
you can't talk [ __ ] in thailand about
about what about the king
about anything what pretty much nah i've
not heard this
i'm thai by the way yes have you seen
the picture of
the king and then his [ __ ] have to
sit on the floor
they can't even sit on the same like
terrorism for real
yeah i'm like damn this fool is crazy
wait are you making that up
no oh every picture you see him like
he's like this right in his like golden
outfit and then the [ __ ] [ __ ]
chicks just sitting on the floor like
like [ __ ] crossing that queen or his
concubine queen
like queen sit there queen oh cause dude
because it's comfy down there oh is it
he wants her to have the comfy seat does
she have a little couch
no it's you know those little couches
it's confused if it's a couch or a chair
it's like a chair but it's long and then
the ladies
they they sit like this on it
oh like that the foot of your bed this
is called a chase
that's a chase yeah it's like it's long
like this way
and it's got a little bit like that or
it's like a pup
and then you go like this and you take
photos on it and then if your therapist
is talking to you you lay on it those
type
i don't know if the therapist i think
it's like a queen's chair oh you see
yeah queen sideways therapist i've seen
that
like in movies and stuff where people
just lay down yeah
like me and joe don't watch the same
movies i thought that was just a couch
anyway back to thailand so recently
this guy he tweeted out this
he tweeted this out okay so it has this
thai paperwork here for a rest and then
this
one star review of a resort of
thailand one star for
you talk a thailand about thailand okay
so then that tweet he captioned it with
thailand's definition laws are very
severe in particular when it comes to
online content a couple of weeks ago
a friend of a friend was arrested at his
school for posting a
one star review on google maps about a
resort he visited
on kong chang yes you heard right like
he got arrested at work he's like you
talk [ __ ] about the business
so like every business has five stars
there damn to jail
everything's just one maybe it has to be
like extremely factual
i've never heard of that but also i
haven't been in thailand in years so
maybe this might be something new that
came up with the rise of like
yelling using yeah maybe because i mean
i do know my dad was irritated at some
of our yelp reviews on the restaurant oh
they're annoying
yeah they don't even they don't even
review the food they review like
that person didn't say hello yeah
exactly and you know asian restaurants
like if the food is fire they're going
to be rude to you that's just kind of
like how it is that's like the scale
some people give you a one star review
because the dog across the street
wouldn't shut up
like for real though i actually don't
even mind like uh
people having their criticisms but i
think you have to give the restaurant a
chance to fix it
before you post it i feel that i feel
like hey like oh man i don't like this
place because the food's cold or
whatever right but
did you tell them that the food's cold
and then they offered them the chance to
go oh shouldn't i make you another one
you know they just go they just like
take one bite oh i can't wait to go talk
some [ __ ]
like let the restaurant or establishment
get a chance to fix
the road yeah man i hate the reviews
that are like okay well the food was
great but i'm giving this one
star because the parking lot was
unorganized or some [ __ ] like that like
come on bro
yeah come on you do that don't you gio
yeah yeah i knew it so
the review the one star review it says
the staff was not friendly nobody could
smile the restaurant manager was very
rude and full of himself he is from the
czech republic
there are other hotels with better
friendlier staff avoid this place as if
it was the coronavirus
so he's not even a thai local well well
the restaurant owner's not a thai local
right
no no so this is taking place in
thailand in a resort and then this
person writing the review
he's an expat living in thailand but in
a different area
so he was kind of doing like a local
tourism kind of thing
so that's why he stayed at this resort
for one night but now he's going to stay
in jail for 20 years
jail for takashi up to two years he's
facing one
yes for having his own opinion don't
[ __ ] around that's the initial
reaction right that opinion is
defamation
it's [ __ ] a [ __ ] man yeah that's what
they're claiming that's defamation so
initially
when that tweet went out everyone was
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
resort why would they
press charges against one review that's
insane like that's just making the
the resort look even worse so then
uh this dude that initially posted it he
actually started getting
getting some stuff from the hotel side
the resort side
and so they came out with a five-page
statement
explaining their side of things oh nice
pretty much
says so the first page says there are
three [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i'm from czech republic [ __ ] you we
don't play
yeah so they said that there are three
main reasons that forced them to file a
complaint
you made me do it they said we are not
suing him for just a single bad review
so number one he
left fabricated stories on his reviews
on tripadvisor and google that included
xenophobic connotations accusations of
slavery and even comments that could
mislead readers to associate our
property with coronavirus number two
he had been posting reviews roughly one
or two weeks apart with
obvious definite uh default defamatory
intentions we chose to file a complaint
to serve as a deterrent
as we understood he may continue to
write negative reviews week
after week for the foreseeable future
and then reason number three is despite
our multiple efforts to contact him to
resolve this
in an amicable way for well over a month
he chose to ignore us completely he only
replied to our emails
and messages on review sites etc once he
had been notified by
of our complaints by the authorities so
pretty much this whole story is from the
resort side
is that the guest and a friend stayed
there for one night
and that night they ended up eating at
the restaurant at the resort
but they brought in alcohol like outside
alcohol
premises so then they were charged they
were charged a
corkage fee of 500 baht and so
at that point that's when this guest and
the guy
like his friend like they started
complaining and saying like nah like
we just paid a [ __ ] ton for this room
i'm not going to pay for this quirkage
fee
my friend is like five bucks by the way
but isn't that isn't that normal
yeah everybody charges fee yeah and
that's yeah 500
that's five dollars dude like they're
like i won't stand for this
that's outrageous you're trying to rip
us off yeah so then
uh then the the resort says that the
negotiation resulted in the guest and
his friend drinking their outside
alcohol without paying the portage fee
in our restaurant
so then the next day they checked out
and then
the day after that is when they received
the first review on tripadvisor
written in both thai and in english
stating the following so here's here's
the actual review on tripadvisor
here i'll read it inside okay just
kidding i can't read that
so he says do not sleep here don't
support modern day slavery of thai
people the staff are not friendly
because of their management
the foreigners treat the staff like
slave
slaves there is one that is really bad
he is from the czech republic
he is the restaurant manager not only
does he treat the staff like slaves he
also acts like he is more important and
better than the guests in the hotel
please don't support this modern day
slavery there are a lot of other hotels
on the island
wait are they foreigners too though
so this man he wrote
his name's wesley so sure he's saying
that he's
wesley so he's american
living in thailand oh so he's saying
like from his
western perspective that he thought the
corkage fee was outrageous
and whatever we have that in america you
stupid [ __ ] it's outrageously low
i know that's what it is like that's
awesome i know we're bringing wine to
every place like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this dude
it's less of like
for him leaving a bad review and more
like almost like um
harassment you know what i'm saying if
he's continuously leaving bad reviews
and
and saying [ __ ] like that accusing them
of slavery right
that's real definition calling out his
like ethnicity too exactly so then
right so after the the five page
response from the resort that's when
the initial guy that posted on twitter
because you remember he's a friend of a
friend which is this guy
the guy that saved the resort so then
this dude ends up having his own
statement
and it looks like this oh damn dude this
one
and this one two pages jeez these
[ __ ] like to write
okay i'm not gonna read this but just
from reading his statement
i'm like dude you sound like a
complaining ass [ __ ] like
that's why they had to run away from
america but his friend wasn't arrested
though
so his friend wasn't he even talks about
how his friend was so nice and he was
like the good one
in that whole art altercation kind of
thing i can't imagine going on vacation
and then feeling
so frustrated that i'm gonna waste my
vacation time on writing these things
i'm like oh [ __ ] it that was a bad
experience i'll just go somewhere else
and try to like redeem i think he was on
vacation
though he's not the aren't they there no
they're expats they live there they just
live there they're
yeah but they're on the resort they're
trying to like or like the stakeholders
yeah i guess yeah it's kind of our
weekend getaway yeah it was kind of like
a weekend getaway kind of thing
and but mainly the fact that they
arrested him
while he was at work at a school because
apparently he works at a school
that was like the most [ __ ] up part
for everyone that was reading the story
but then once they
okay kids don't talk a [ __ ] lesson
learned
yeah so pretty much uh
the way it's concluded at this point is
that he has made a statement oh
so he ended up getting booked like he
was taken to jail
and he stayed there a couple of nights
he had to pay a bale of a hundred
thousand
baht and and so forth
and he was outraged and he goes i'm not
gonna stand for this and pay twenty
dollars to get out of jail no the way he
wrote it i was told my bill is 100 000
baht i could not pay it i stayed in a
local prison with
1 150 inmate saturday and sunday night
damn you spent this whole night counting
one two how many [ __ ] am i in
here with
uh thankfully i was able to bail out on
monday evening if found guilty i could
face up to one years
in prison in thailand this one doesn't
know don't learn his [ __ ] lesson
he's still [ __ ] type
100 000 is get this 3
168 this dude is an american
and he doesn't have three thousand
dollars in foreign lands
and he says one years yeah oh no there's
so many other
like spelling errors here right
parentheses like years
one years like i spent one years and
this was an english teacher
i don't know why you guys are making
that up he's just a teacher what other
expat in another country what are they
going to teach
that's probably true english yeah he's a
[ __ ] up
english teacher though english yeah but
even in his
his first page of the statement he's
like after having a
after having a little to drink and
paying so much for the room i got a
little attitude back
so it's just the week he's writing it
too it's like you know you're in the
wrong
but whatever but then even after all
this evidence came about on twitter i
was checking
the initial threads comments and a lot
of people are still
on this dude's side versus the resort a
lot of people are saying that the resort
didn't have to be that petty to go ahead
and
press charges so i think it's okay
because people who um harass businesses
they don't get in trouble
right right and then they can do a lot
of damage to
a lot of people's livelihoods like
they're not just hurting
maybe the person that they didn't like
like the czech guy they're hurting like
the janitor that has nothing to do with
this
and then so if less customers come
because they think it's a racist resort
then they're affecting like let's say
100 people work there
all those hundred people are getting
hurt by this guy's
[ __ ] up actions and i think that
should be punished
just like the same way if a business
does something shady to a customer they
get punished
but what about when the customers do
something [ __ ] up or
this is not even like so the perspective
of what i gathered from twitter
as to why they're on this dude's side
and not the resort is because they're
saying like
we don't know what his experience was
like what if they were
a shitty resort and they they did
deserve those those reviews and
no one can really prove otherwise
because it's this man's experience
my only thing is like yeah i understand
going and having a bad experience and
leaving
leaving a bad review but if it's true
that he kept leaving him like over and
over and over yeah they have proof
because in that five page
statement like they have screenshots i
got the receipts
that's harassment because the thing is
if he really just wanted to remedy
things
he would communicate with them when they
reached out versus like
putting it on like it seemed like just a
petty personal thing
where he just wanted to damage their
business yep
but would you ever not go unless you see
like 20 reviews that all say the same
thing
uh for me like if it's just one random
review sometimes it makes me go
i want to see for myself i'll go to
places with one star i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't know about that
you